So I'm absolutely delighted to have them
visit us today and talk to us a little
bit about how she's managed to build
an unconventional company. Um, so,
so first and foremost,
tell us a little bit about yourself
because you've got an impressive resume
resume,
um,
which goes from being a biologist
to various things and finally,
entrepreneurship.
So tell us how that's all come about.
Okay. Um, Ooh, what do
I start? Okay. So, um,
I was born and raised in Minnesota.
Um,
I was one of those kids
that, um, love to get lost.
So I was always wondering around,
uh,
my mom often tells me
the story of, um, how I,
I let myself out of the apartment that
we were staying at when I was, um,
I think that was one,
it was the middle of the winter and I
walked around the parking lot until child
services came to pick me up. And so she
likes to tell me that story. And so I,
I link that to, um, kind
of to what I'm doing now.
I'm kind of a wander at heart.
Um,
after I left Minnesota, I was about eight
years old. I moved to North Carolina.
Um, and I got into biology
my freshman and sophomore,
junior year of college. And, um,
at the age of 19, I cloned a gene. Uh,
I was one of those like
nerdy kinds of kids.
I was like crushing fruit flies
and just doing really weird things.
And so that led me to traveling around
the state to talk about my research.
I also teamed up with my best friend
who did a lot of anti tobacco work,
um,
at the time.
And we traveled around the country talking
to the young people about big tobacco
and, and how to, how to, um, protect
ourselves against, against them.
And so, um, after after
that I did some travel.
I went and I moved to DC and moved to
San Francisco to organize churches or
pastors of those churches,
uh, in the Fillmore district,
which is the oldest black neighborhood
in San Francisco. And, um,
then I moved back to North
Carolina for my senior year.
I had five years of university. I
stayed an extra year. Um, and, uh,
I started an organization to help
open a civil rights museum. Um,
it was a museum that, um, had had
been open for I think 14 years.
Come on in. I'm sorry. I definitely
put you on the spot. I'm sorry.
Um,
and so
my senior year, this
museum opened and, um,
I decided that I wanted to do something
a little bit different instead of
traveling and living in
San Francisco and DC,
I wanted to try something
international. So, um,
I applied for this program and I got it
and I sold everything that I owned after
I graduated college and I moved to India.
So I was in India for
a little over a year.
I learned Hindi and, um, I lived on
a train for four portion of the year,
so I was just doing all of
these really interesting things.
And I went to India with
braids similar to this.
And so as my,
uh,
diaspora folks know at some point
the brains have to come out.
So I took the braids out and I didn't
know what to do with my hair. Um,
uh, the hair of a lot of Indians
is very different from my own,
and I didn't have anything
to take care of it. So, uh,
my hair started breaking and I,
and I thought to myself, you know,
I don't see any people who looked like me.
I don't see any travelers or any x bats
who I can talk to about what's happening
with my hair. And so the idea
for travel noire was born there.
Um, but I sat on it for two
years. I traveled through Asia,
spent all of my money and ended up broke
back home in southern California at my
mom's house. And so, um,
it's kind of troubling.
More kind of started out of that.
So it was a seed planted
while I was living in India.
And then I kind of came back to the US.
My mom tried to get me into medicine as
again, all of my diasporic folks here,
you all know in our, in,
in, so I'm Nigerian. Um,
and for my mom it was either
you were either a doctor,
a lawyer, an engineer, or a failure.
Like anything else. There was another,
there was this like little box
that you kind of had to fit in.
And so when I came home after
spending all my money traveling,
my mom was like, oh yeah, so
here's this a nursing program.
Here is this doctor's program.
Here's this postbac program.
And after six months I was like,
all right, I love you mom, but, uh,
I'm going to move to San Francisco.
So I had $300 in my bank account.
And, uh, somebody offered a
couch for me in San Francisco.
I'm on treasure island. I don't know
if anybody's been to San Francisco,
but there's this little island called
treasure island between San Francisco and
Oakland if you're to cross the bay bridge.
So I lived there.
I slept on a couch slash bed for
six months and I worked four jobs.
And I had this like really interesting,
like I sold luxury sunglasses.
I was a nanny, which was very
short lived. And, um, I, uh,
helped my friend, senator, our
company, and, um, what else did I do?
Um,
and I was an intern at a startup company
and being an intern of that startup
company was what kind of fine
tune this idea that I had,
um, for travel new are. So that is
a very long answer to your question,
but I hope it gives some background.
Absolutely. And you know,
it sounds like you chose the favorite
option came to have Nigerian parents
wanted,
hence you funding travel traveling well,
but tell us a little bit about what travel
and why it actually is when it does.
Yeah. And who you talk to.
Woody Allen says. Sure.
So started traveling to war in 2013.
Um,
and this was after,
you know,
not seeing travelers who look like me.
If you go to any store,
you pull any travel magazine off the,
off the stands,
you'll never see somebody
who looks like me.
You'll never see a black girl in
Italy or in, you know, whatever.
And what that meant for a lot of people
was if they didn't see somebody who
looked like them traveling and
all these different places,
they then thought that it might have
been dangerous for them to travel or that
travel might not be for them,
or that travel is only for the rich
and famous like Beyonce and Jay z or
whatever. And so I wanted to bring
that down to earth. I mean, I was,
when I was living in India,
I was flying on Air Asia for $8
to Malaysia from India. I mean,
it was crazy. And so I wanted
people to, um, to know this.
And so traveling was started out as,
um,
an editorial site.
So we had about a hundred writers who
lived all over the globe who shared their
love of travel and what it was
like being a person of color. Um,
while they traveled. I remember
being in, um, I think I was in, uh,
the Netherlands and somebody
asked me, they said, well,
what's the difference between a black
person traveling or black American
traveling and a white American
traveling? And I, I told him,
I gave him a couple of examples,
but one that stood out was in China.
Um, when I would go into a
store and I'd ask her for, um,
facewash they'd give me skin whitening
cream or a kid would come and try to rub
off my skin thinking it was dirt
and there was like white, white,
white underneath or people who would
constantly pull my hair or, um,
there were all of these
different experiences that
were very unique to a certain
subset of people that
nobody was talking about.
So we started out as an editorial site
and then we grew from that to hosting
live classes about how to get your boss
to let you work from anywhere in the
world or how to get paid to travel. And
we started building an audience that way.
And one thing that I learned that we did,
we didn't make money for 18 months,
so 18 months.
We spent the time building an audience
and we just offered a lot of free things,
a lot of free classes. Um, and when
we did end up selling a product,
we sold out of it.
And so we started as an editorial site.
We started doing a lot of free
things and then we launched, um,
traveling to our experiences
in July of 2015, uh,
travel noire experiences their small
group experiences, about 14 people there,
14 strangers from anywhere in the world.
They meet in one of
our seven destinations,
and we take them for the ride of
their life. Um, it was inspired.
Um,
it was inspired by my time in India.
It was my time in India was awesome,
but it was also like very challenging.
Who in here has been to India?
All right.
So y'all know that India is not people.
Some people used to tell me,
oh,
like Indians,
like traveling to like any other Asian
country or it's like traveling to any
other country. Um, and it's not, it's like
very difficult. It's very challenging.
You either love it or you hate it.
And I thought to myself,
if India had not been so challenging,
I would not have,
have grown so much or been so transformed
by it. And so I thought to myself,
how can I compress that into seven days
where you challenge people enough that
you know, they don't hate you, right?
Cause it's a vacation. But you also, um,
build in moments of transformation.
So on any one of our trips,
you'll find days that challenge these,
that lifts you up days that may make you
upset. Like in Cape Town for instance,
we talk a lot about apartheid in Jo'Burg,
we talk a lot about apartheid. Um,
and we go in and talk to people and we
go into people's homes and we cook with
them. And so the, the idea
behind those experiences,
it is that they are an experience.
It's like you're living just like a logo,
which isn't easy in a lot of places. Um,
and so we launched tn experiences.
We run about 60 trips a year
across five continents. Um,
each trip comes with a
private photographer. Um,
and that's because I didn't want people
to look through travel through their
phone.
Right?
I wanted people to be present and I wanted
people to really enjoy the moment and
enjoy conversations and not try and
Graham everything or a snapchat,
everything, uh, or tweet things. Um,
and so those are the experiences I
typically seven days, eight nights,
seven days, six nights. Um, and then
we launched compass earlier this year,
which is a platform that
helps travelers travel better.
So if you want to move abroad,
if you want to travel solo,
if you want to move your family abroad,
we have resources that we deliver
every single week to help you do that.
So that's what traveling war is in.
I always tell everything in the story,
just, just so you know. So sometimes
the answers are very long, um,
but they're with me or whatever.
Then so that step off to,
you know,
towards being an entrepreneur is obviously
one that some people are that I'm
nervous about. How did you
find it? Like what was it,
what emotions did you go through when you
were making that decision and actually
deciding that this was going
to be for you? Um, well, the
decision was made for me.
I didn't make the decision. Um, so, uh,
two days before my birthday actually,
my boss sent me an email,
a firing me, um, and this was
so was two days of my birthday.
Um,
and I think two weeks before
like a vacation that I was
supposed to take and um,
that kind of forced my hand, you
know, because I didn't, I wasn't,
I was planning on leaving a couple
of months later, but it was a,
it was such a blessing because had I left
a couple months later on my own terms,
I wouldn't have gotten like the
severance, but she, since she fired me,
I was able to keep that severance,
which went into this,
this pocket of mine to help me kind of
live for the next 18 months that travel
noire didn't make any
money. Um, and so when,
so entrepreneurship I would say is
probably like the hardest thing I've ever
done. Anybody who is an
entrepreneur who has been,
we'll probably say the very same things.
I mean,
just last couple of months ago I was like,
you know,
like what if I just like give it all
up and like just buy a little house in
Italy with no Internet, no electricity,
and just look at the water.
I'll be fine. I'll be quiet. I live a nice
quiet existence. Every entrepreneur has,
has talked like that with themselves and
it's a matter of really understanding
your mission and what you are
called to do in this world.
And it's just hard. It's hard. Like it's,
it's not easy. Like I, we have a team,
I have a team of full time
folks with eight, eight people,
but you count all of our contractors
in and that brings it up to 30 and just
managing your,
like you,
you're holding these people's
lives in your hand and you know,
every move that you make it like
their livelihood depends on it.
And that pressure of having to figure out,
you know,
whether or not you have
this really great idea,
but it's not financially feasible,
but you want to do it.
You can't do it because you have these,
you have the livelihoods.
Of these people in your hands,
people who have families,
people who are considering proposing
to their significant others, you know,
you have all of these different things.
And so it's, it's been a challenge,
but it's also pretty
beautiful. I mean, you,
you build something out
of the dust and it's, um,
one of the things that I thought was
really cool last year in January,
we had a team of four people and,
um,
got a tweet one morning in
January that we had been named by,
by fast company as one of
the most innovative companies
in the world. And, um,
it was, it was kind of mind blowing
because we were such a small team,
but it was kind of validating too that,
you know,
anybody with an idea that has a
pension towards execution, um,
can really do some good in the world.
And so that's what I've,
I've learned about entrepreneur.
There's a lot that I've learned about
entrepot I could talk about all day, but,
um, it's really hard. And I tell
people, people ask me what their, uh,
advices for,
for wanting to be entrepreneurs.
And a lot of times I tell them not to
do it. And I know that's really bad,
but it really is hard.
And when you think about entrepreneurs
that are charismatic specifically,
they have, um, I or rate
of depression, right?
And they have like, you know, being
a charismatic entrepreneur who,
who are you going to talk to
you when things go wrong, right?
Like if you have a significant other,
perfect.
But are there people around
you that really understand
the perils and the plight
of being an entrepreneur?
And I know it's hard to like put into
words for people who aren't entrepreneurs,
but, um, sometimes it can get really
challenging, but it's also beautiful.
So there's a, there's a balance, right?
So just to pick up on your point around,
you know,
needing to have other people to talk to,
who have your mentors been over your
journey with traveling while, yeah. So,
um, I have a group of advisors, they all
come from different walks of life. Um,
but I also have,
um,
a group of entrepreneurs that I meet
with maybe four or five times a year.
Um,
these are entrepreneurs from all over the
world and we all come together to talk
about issues and what we're going through.
And one thing that I've learned is
that no matter how much money you make,
you're still, you're still messed up.
Like everybody's still has problems.
Everybody has problems.
You think when you get into a room with
somebody who has a $200 million company
that they're just going to
be like relaxing and Maxon,
but it's just the problem's
magnified on a different,
on a different scale and
a different level. Um,
and so that's one thing that I've learned
is that problem that your problems
don't go away or you know, money.
I mean, they just, they're,
they're still there just in
different ways. Yeah. Cool.
And congratulations on being
named on a excuse. She ended
30. Thank you. Thank you.
Subsea fantastic from last year.
So apart from that particular highlight,
one of the highs of you had,
um,
other HIEs.
Uh,
I would say having a team of
really cool people, um, you know,
it's always great when you're able to
work with people that you get along with.
And people who are just a lot of fun,
um,
who are grounded in the same
mission that you're grounded in.
I can take a month off and not have to
worry about anything because they handle
everything. Um, and so I think that that's
been the biggest blessing, uh, launch,
launching compass this year has
also been a big blessing. Um,
I'm trying to think. There've
been so many highs, but I,
I tell my team not to get caught
up on all of them. Right. And, um,
so while we do celebrate, you
know, what we've got going on,
we are also still very rooted in the
work that we have to do because they have
more people to reach and we have more,
you know,
we have more people that we want more
people whose lives we want to help
transform. And so we do
celebrate the wins, but then we,
we go back and we, we, we dive into,
to the work that we have to do.
Yeah.
And you have hundreds of thousands of
followers on social media at the moment.
Um, so what role has digital actually
played and helping build your brand?
Huge. I mean, I, you talk
about millennials today and,
and how much our lives are kind of
intertwined with social media. Um,
I remember it was the first starting
at the travel to our Instagram account.
It was so hard to find black
travelers. Like I, I would,
I would sit and browse on Instagram for
hours to find one photo and we would
post 12 photos a day. So if you can
imagine like it just took, it was,
it was a lot of,
a lot of hard work,
but over time and that easier people
like seeing themselves featured in,
in different places.
So that made it easier for people to kind
of tag their photos. And so it's been,
it's been such a great help.
In fact,
people when they tell me they've heard
of and water the first place that they
say that they've heard of
travel north Instagram.
And so we use Instagram as
like the top of the funnel.
And so a lot of times when
we need somebody to do
something and we have a call
to action, we start on Instagram
or we start an email. Um,
and we direct people where we want to go,
which has been really,
which has been really cool.
And I'm sort of back to more your
travel and personal experiences.
What's the craziest place
you've ever visited?
The craziest place I've ever visited.
Um,
probably India. I will always say
India for any, any crazy adventure.
Um, crazy, craziest place I visited. So,
uh, my boyfriend and I, um,
he came to India while I
was living there and we, uh,
took a bus like a four by four
up to Kashmir, which is, uh,
the disputed a territory of India,
India and Pakistan. And um,
it was so beautiful though.
It was so beautiful,
but it was quite treacherous getting
there and we had to sit in the,
it wasn't the trunk,
but it was like,
if you imagine like a jeep
and you'd have the chair,
you have the drivers see in the passenger
seat and then you have like another
row of seats. We were in the back, like
where there were no seats, just the floor.
So we were just sitting in the
back looking at the outside and we,
um, we rode on this, um,
this canyon with no fence,
but it was just like,
it was the craziest thing. It was
the craziest adventure. People die,
people die on that road.
Um, and uh, you know,
we got stopped by,
um,
they're either cows or goats that were
crossing and it caused the whole traffic
jam. And, um, for those that
have been to India, you know,
how cows do, they just do whatever
they do and everybody just stops. So,
you know, but it was
cool. It was fun. Right.
I'm just going to open it up to the
audience to see if anyone has got any
questions for them.
You've got to Mike,
so
thank you.
Thanks so much again,
my love the way that you want to
have questions and stories. Um,
so I was just wondering what you think,
what you know now,
what would you have told yourself when
you first decided to start traveling?
You are,
that's a good question.
MMM.
Back then.
Hmm,
I'd probably say have a closer
relationship with God. Um,
and I think that, so when, when I
first started traveling new, our,
I had like a team, but it was a t
because we didn't make any money.
We couldn't afford to pay anybody.
And I think that the way that I treated
people back then, I went, it wasn't bad.
Like I,
you know,
I wasn't yelling at people or kicking
them or doing anything like that.
But I think that what I
think that, that, you know,
had I had a closer and
tighter relationship with God,
I would have been much calmer.
I would have been nicer to people.
Um, and so I think that's
probably one of the big things,
um, because I had a team fallout
before we hired a new team.
So if you can imagine running a company
and then she leaves your team and then
you have to kind of have to start over.
Um,
and then another thing that I
would say would probably be,
um,
I dunno,
like sometimes people sometimes,
because we're not out there,
like we're not hosting a lot of
events and we're not, um, you know,
we're not at every event.
People kind of see us as standoffish
or a little like secretive or you know,
whatever. And it's, it's not, it's
not the case. And I, and I, it's,
I guess it's maybe it's just like the
ethic or the or the ethics or the drive.
Uh, we just love our work and we love
doing good work and sometimes we just get
consumed in doing that good work,
but not being afraid to like pick out
of the curtain every once in a while and
say what's up to folks. So, yeah.
How did you find your team
when you were still smell?
Um,
so I think everybody,
everybody for the most part has been
really intrigued with this idea from about
like working for, from anywhere or
working for a travel company or, you know,
we have unlimited vacations and you
don't have an office. And so, um,
obviously we couldn't
pay people back then,
so this is so before we could pay people.
Um,
I think people would just really attracted
to the brand and the culture of the
brand.
Um,
and people want it to be associated
with what we were doing. Um,
so it was,
it wasn't difficult to find a team.
I mean it's always difficult to find
like a quality quality team. Um,
but it wasn't challenging to find people
who love travel because back then there
not that there was a small subset
of black folks trap traveling.
There were a ton, but we
weren't all connected. And I,
and I think once people found that nexus,
they kind of wanted to
gravitate towards it.
So some people were like old friends
that I brought into this project and some
people, if you had a fellowship
program and the fellowship program,
I taught you how to earn enough miles for
a free vacation anywhere you wanted in
the world. And a lot of people
were like, oh shoot. Okay.
Like you're not paying
me, but you're, you're,
you're showing me how to travel for free.
And that's like the next best
of all your work on Instagram. Amazing.
So that's one of the people who found it.
Okay. Um, so I'm going to
talk about building of culture
and um, that's, you know,
previously swat for us set up and
that's one of the biggest, um,
I guess like studying,
it's pretty tough to do it.
How did you go about sort of building
culture and especially from Instagram sort
of getting the follow up
base because you know,
you've got lots of travelers that you
sort of connected in there and sort of,
I guess you predicted a group of travelers
all over the world or an Instagram
post travels through that trouble anymore.
So how do you go about doing that and
just sort of creating this community? Um,
and then my second question was about the
locations that you have already listed.
How do you go about selecting those and
sort of organizing the experiences? Um,
for one eight, you didn't,
Cape Town and most experiences,
you see this as very touristy because
you don't learn about sort of the history
and what's going on in the actual,
people will leave there.
So how did you go about just so creative?
I have a very short term memory,
so I'm going to try,
I'm going to try and
remember both of them. Okay.
So the first question is
how do we build culture? Um,
culture wasn't, extension is an
extension of who we are as a team.
So right when I had that team fall off,
we had like two people that stayed.
And so what I did was I said,
all right, we got a bit,
we had to build a tighter culture.
So we had a summer culture
project and we worked,
we had I think a Friday all hands
on deck for like two months.
And we built out the entire culture. We
build art, we want unlimited vacations,
we want, um, we want to be
able to work from anywhere.
I feel like now if I went back to
my team and said, all right, y'all,
we're gonna put an office in Chicago,
they would like revolt. They, they,
they really love being able
to work from anywhere. Um,
we, you know, we pay
their cell phone bills,
like we have all of these different
things that we do to make it easy to,
um, work for travel in New
Orleans. So our culture is,
was an extension of who we are.
So everything is figureoutable
is one of our tenets.
And that just means that if I can't find,
like I can probably tell
I slipped this chair over,
even if it doesn't have a name on it,
there is,
I will find out who made
this chair some way somehow.
And that's one of the
cultures of the team.
That's one of the tenants for our culture
of the team is that if we can't find a
solution right away, we,
we figure it out. Um,
and so every time we, uh,
are considering candidates,
we run them through a really
interesting, um, questionnaire. And it's,
I don't know if it's similar,
like y'all Google used to have
something where they, it was like, Huh,
so how many pennies are in
the empire state building?
Or like something like that.
We got rid of those. But yeah.
So you got rid of those questions.
We actually have that.
We have the pennies question
in our, and one of our um, um,
forms because it goes
back to that everything is
figureoutable value instead of
telling me what the number
is for that particular,
like how many pennies are
in empire state building.
You can ask me questions like,
is there furniture in the,
is it furniture in the lobby? How many
people are there? Is, you know, is this,
are the coins? Um, like from the UK,
are they American pennies?
Like whatever. Um,
it allows us to see who people are
without them telling us who they are,
if that makes sense. Um, so we
also have one of our values is,
um, uh, be you stayed true.
Um, everybody on our team is weird.
Like the weirdest people that I know.
And I'm also weird, but I want
people who come into the travel,
our team to also feel
like they are welcoming.
They're weird and it's okay to be
weird because we're all weird. Okay.
So that's Kinda,
so we have kind of like,
it's like a very kind of
like a familial vibe. It's,
it's kind of like almost how I would
imagine Google was back in 90 back in
[inaudible] 98.
Um,
and so has the culture question
for the destination questions.
Um, sometimes we choose places based on
where I've been or where some of my staff
has been. Um, and then we go
there, we travel there and we,
I remember going to Cape Town
who's been to Cape Town. All right.
So we've got folks who have been to Cape
Town. Um, so when I landed in Cape Town,
I wanted to, to build an
experience that I could relate to,
which was a black Cape Town experience.
Um, but when I landed in Cape Town,
um, I sit in camps bay. I don't know
if y'all are familiar with camps bay,
but it's like near the,
near the water near the ocean and the
only people of color that I saw where the
help. Um, and I was like, hmm.
So in order to build an
experience that I can relate to,
I have to find people who look like me.
And so I was,
I was racking my brain trying to
figure out how to build the Cape Town
experience. That was one that focus
on culture, meeting people. Um,
and so I ended up
figuring it out. And, um,
I remember we were at a point where we
were trying to figure out whether to
include Robben Island, um, in the tour.
And I talked to one of the
guys who grew up in long ago,
which is a township outside of
Cape Town. And I said, you know,
I'm kind of torn between
this, between um, uh,
Robben Island and the district six museum.
And we landed on having those stories
told by the people who live them
themselves in the township.
Um,
and so we encourage people on their free
day if they want to go to Robben Island
to go there. But, um,
the guards and Robben Island don't even
like giving the tours there because it
reminds, these are former prisoners
who spent their lives in this,
in this prison, and they're now forest
because they have to make a living.
Nobody will hire them to retell the
story that were so painful for them.
And so when building that experience
and all of our experiences,
really, we have to be very
sensitive to all of these things.
So people are paying for that sensitivity,
if you will. Right. So understanding
the issues as they exist.
People still go to Robben Island and they
find out for themselves, just like in,
um, Bali we haven't experienced in
Bali. People go to the elephant. Um,
they're not elephant farms,
but they're like the elephant.
I'm not sanctuaries with the elephant
places. I don't know what they're called,
but people go there and then
they'd come back sad, right?
Like they realize for themselves that
this wasn't like this wasn't what I
expected.
But we get a lot of questions like,
why don't you include like an elephant
tour? Like why don't you do x?
So why don't you do y?
And it's our job to be mindful and to be
sensitive to how the locals really live
their lives and how to create a
space where we're only working with,
um, local vendors. We're building
up economies and things like that.
So a part of it,
the mantra is om travel to meet people,
not see things. Right. So traveling
to have conversations with people.
Sometimes I know when I try,
when I've traveled in the past,
I would go to like monuments and like
take pictures. But at the end of the day,
what I really remembered about the trip
for the people that I met and the homes
that people were invited me
into and the coffee shops,
we sat and talked and whatever.
And so that's kind of the philosophy
that we use to build those experiences.
Yeah,
you're welcome.
So I have a questions around money.
It's one question
pop up.
So like how can I make someone transition
from employment to entrepreneurship?
Because, see, when union payment, you'll
be feeded and at least honesty, CPD.
So if you decide,
you know what,
I'm just going to follow my dream and
you need to be able to generate revenue
because at the end of the year or human
being, you need a roof, need to eat.
He tells me everything. So, and you don't
know how long that business is way to,
you know, uh, how long have you sensed
it would take to go to [inaudible] team,
the current standards of
living that you have now.
So like that's something that I think,
and then again,
the question of passion and also being,
maybe they saw the right word to use,
but realistic. So like I'm passionate
about this idea by the end of the day,
do you got bills to pay? Right?
So, so how do you like, you know,
how do you like is cause that's,
that's,
that's a conversation I need to have
yourself, right? For sure. So how,
how do you go about that? This,
this, of this whole money thing.
And maybe the type question would be,
how do you know this is
the right and to stop?
Maybe you have a nice idea you're working
on in, but the money's not coming in.
So,
yeah.
All right. I, Gosh, I
got to short. Okay. Okay.
So first question was,
um,
the first question was, I know
what you're getting at. Okay.
So incident when I was living
in San Francisco, after I
spent my money traveling,
I live with my mom for six months.
I moved to San Francisco
and I had all those jobs.
I had a $3 a day budget.
So it was either I use that $3 for
the bus or I use it to eat food.
And with any startup,
well not any startup,
but a lot of startups in San Francisco,
they had free food just
like I'll do it Google.
So I was able to kind of offset that.
But $3 a day isn't that a lot,
you know, um, at all.
And so that was the budget that I had
for six months. So when you think about,
and not every entrepreneur's
journey is like that,
but a good number of folks,
when they leave their high paying jobs,
you maintaining that standard of living,
you have to reconcile that because if
you're making six figures and you are
trying to start a company that is making
$0 million and 0 million cents, um,
if you quit your job, then you're,
you're, you're not, it's not,
it's just not going. The numbers aren't
going shake out. So I had to, I remember,
uh, after I got fired from my job, those
checks stop coming. But I had saved,
I think I saved maybe like $15,000
or something, but that was the,
for the next 18 months that I had
to live like $15,000 for 18 months.
That's like,
that's not a lot of money.
And so I had to move out of my apartment
and I was living in San Francisco.
I moved out of my apartment and I
just traveled for six months. And so,
you know,
there are lots of different ways that you
have to reconcile what your passion is
and your current standard of living.
And how comfortable you are.
You have to be comfortable with
being uncomfortable. Otherwise,
at the first sign of hardship,
you're just going to quit and you're
going to go back to your, the,
the high paying job, which I think is a
lot. It's a danger for a lot of people.
They don't give their their business or
they idea enough time to really incubate.
When I was,
uh,
when I started traveling Nawara
while I still had my full time job,
so I started traveling war in 2013.
I got my job in 2000.
I started talking to Laura
two months after I got my job.
So all I needed was that security net
and I was like, okay, boom, this idea,
let's, let's get it going. I started
traveling to war and I didn't quit until,
well, I got fired. So I was
forced into entrepreneurship,
but I ran with that idea while I
had a steady paycheck and I wasn't,
I didn't like quit the job
and then start child new are.
So I think that's also
something to consider. Hi.
I'm also a huge traveling offline.
Um,
so you were talking about how one of the
main things I get to through the tough
times is knowing what your mission is and,
and hang onto that.
So I'm wondering what is your mission
is personally or the company and how did
you come about pulling it together?
I looked back at um, my thread,
so I went, I told my mom,
cause this like Oprah event like a
couple of years ago. And Oprah said,
what's your thread?
What does the thing you were doing when
you were a child that you can link to
what you're doing now? Right?
So if you, if you were you,
there's one story that she had that she
gave of a girl who loves to me organized
and she got a file cabinet for her seventh
birthday and was the happiest person
ever.
And now she's like one of
the best accountants in the
country or like something
crazy like that.
But what is the thing that you were doing
when you were young that you stopped
doing? Because people may be saying,
Oh, you can't make any money with this,
or oh like you can't do x.
And tie that into the thing that you
were the most passionate about. Right.
So for me, my mom told me the story
when I was one and I left the house.
I would just let myself out.
And I was just walking around.
I was probably throwing snowballs,
like having a good making snow
angels just doing as a one year old.
And so she was like, this
is, this was who you were.
Like you are always wandering around
trying to find the newest adventures.
And so I often tell people I will
go anywhere that's not war torn.
You know, I'm, uh, I, I,
and I want everybody to feel the same
way that anywhere that you traveled to is
your place to travel to and
you are welcome in that place.
And so I think that the mission of
traveling to Ark came out of that.
Like you also belong here and you know,
you don't just because you don't see,
I grew up in Minnesota,
Minnesota is very white.
Um,
I was like one of three
people in my class, but,
and so I grew up living a
very different life. Like I,
I was this like one black girl with
the exotic name. People were like,
where are you from? So I shortened
my name to Zim instead of Zim Ozo,
which is my full name.
And then I moved to North Carolina where
I was crushing fruit flies and cloning
genes. Like there were no other
black girls in my school who were,
who were doing those things. And so I
was always used to just being the other,
and it took me time to figure
out that that was also okay.
And I wanted everybody to be able
to feel okay with being other.
And so I think the travel, our
mission kind of came out of that. Hey,
you sound like the emails you send.
Very [inaudible] go back.
How do you find time for self?
Oh, so I block out, um, so a
couple of a couple of things.
So from like 6:00 AM to
10:00 AM I have like,
just like nothing.
So I usually do a lot of like praying
or reading the Bible or like studying
scripture or something like that.
And then I take a one week off per month.
Um,
and yeah,
so I take one week off a month and
that it doesn't usually doesn't include
vacations.
So I kind of mix those all in as well.
I am one of the most restful
people you'll meet. I've,
I have friends that I
know that are really busy.
I just have them block off a month in
their calendar and send me an invite.
So I know that if they change the days,
you know,
if you send somebody a confirmation,
if you change the time or whatever,
they get the notification.
So if I get any notification from my
friends that they moved their off times,
I'm calling them and then we're
going to have a serious discussion.
And so I think that rest is so important
because who are you without rest?
Like if you, if you all worked from
January to December with no days off,
y'all be Frizzell frazzle shaken gray
hair, hair, falling out, everything.
And you wouldn't be of no use to anybody.
And so I think that of the things
that I've learned you like, you know,
you have some entrepreneurs that are
like work til you die, like sleep.
Don't like, whatever, like don't
sleep ever. And I'm like, what?
Like it doesn't make any sense.
So I think that, you know, it's,
I've been very intentional about
the time that I had to myself. Yeah.
Hey, thanks for being here. First of all,
I would like to know what's next for
treble norm and maybe are there any of the
industries a,
was it lack of representation of people
of color that you're looking into
branching into?
Excellent,
good question. So for TN
experiences, more destinations, um,
we're launching a new
destination this summer. Um,
we're also looking at different segments.
So I know that I've,
I've gone to a lot of conferences where
people who are 50 plus for instance will
be like, I want to go on
your chosen. Everybody,
everybody on those trips look
like they're like my children.
They could be my kids. Um, and so,
you know, things like that. Um,
there are always places that need
more representation, I think. Um,
we've thought about interiors.
We, I mean travel kind of like,
it intersects a lot of
different industries and
really interesting and unique
ways. Um, so those are,
those are some of the things that we're
thinking about in terms of what's next.
Yeah. I, Hey.
Um,
when you were talking,
you talked about execution and how does
importance for each other and ship.
And when you answered your question also
about taking time for herself and we
don't rest. And I, she liked,
most of us always have the
solution that we're going to do.
What's important now and
we're going to rest later.
Or You like this since day one or did
you have this moment of, you know,
I think in six months when it's going
to take off, I'll rest then her. So, uh,
so I was where I was actually working.
So when I moved to San Francisco,
I had the four jobs, right?
So I was like a crazy person.
And then when I got my full
time job as a producer,
I'm in San Francisco and
I started travel noire.
I did those two jobs simultaneously.
So I would work on travel and war from
6:00 AM to 9:00 AM go to work from nine
to five and then work from traveling
to work on traveling war from five to
midnight and then like do it all over
again until I got myself sick. Um,
and like I wound up in a hospital
and then I realize like, oh,
I don't know, like I can't,
you can't do that forever.
Like hustle isn't sustainable forever.
There is a period of
time and a place for it,
but it can't be an everyday thing.
And so that was maybe in May.
So then I was like, all right,
so we'll travel noire is
doing pretty good. Um,
I've saved up enough money to like be,
well, it wasn't enough. It was like,
it was not, I mean, whatever is
relative, but you know, um, I was like,
okay, so there has to be a time
limit for like working these two,
two jobs simultaneously. Like they're
both full time jobs. Um, and so,
you know, July was my date that I was
going to say, all right, I'm out of here,
but that my boss had other
plans. So, um, so yeah,
I think in the beginning it was very
much like work, work, work, work,
work, work all the time, 24, seven,
but then you get sick and
you can't work anymore.
Like you can't wear your body if you're,
if you don't give your body rest,
your body's going to force you to rest.
And at the point where your
body is forcing you to harass
you, like just no good,
no good to anybody.
And so it's a lesson that I've
had to learn time and time again,
and those periods of like
working, working, working,
my body is like, all right,
not today. And you just have
to listen because you just,
you can't do anything. Um,
so I think it's a, it's a constant
lesson that as entrepreneurs,
you're taught all the time.
I'm going to see your
last question, sorry. Um,
do you think the idea is more important
than the execution or is institution?
Thank you.
Execution. Execution is more important
than idea. Cause you, listen, I,
when I was in living in India,
I had a spreadsheet of like all of these
ideas that I had 80% of them now exist
today. Right? Like I just had these
ideas and I was like, oh, like I do,
I could be an idea machine and, but
if I don't execute on them, they just,
they're just there, you know, there do
they just exist and excellent execution.
Like you can find ideas and that
you could find ideas anywhere,
but if you have an execution mindset
that any idea that comes your way,
like you can make happen.
Yeah. Execution. Great. Well on that note,
um, I'll just say thank
you so much for coming in.
I think it's been an inspirational
talk, um, on so many different levels.
You've taught us that, you know, we can,
we should follow her dreams first
and foremost. You had this, you know,
one lust biting of the age of one,
which is pretty amazing,
but also the importance of rest.
And that's not easy to be an entrepreneur
that you running your own business is
not the nirvana that some people
think it is. But if read reading,
hold on and challenge yourself and
create a culture within your own company,
it could be something that your dreams
are made of. So thank you again.
You are a good summary.
[inaudible] remember what I
talked about five minutes ago?
That's cool.
Thank you.
Thanks again.
[inaudible].